وفي اخبار التقنيه ايضا تفاعل واسع شهادته
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي حول العالم بعد
تسريب بيانات اكثر من نصف مليار مستخدم
لتطبيق واتساب منها بياناته لاكثر من 28
مليون مستخدم في السعوديه فقط يعني هذا
التسليم وفقا لمختصين امكانيه استهداف
المستخدمين بالاعلانات وايضا استهدافهم
بالهندسه الاجتماعيه للاختراق وغيرها
استديوهاتنا من رياض انضم الينا الخبير
التقنيه عبد العزيز محمد عبد العزيز حياك
الله حياك عبد العزيز رقم كبير اكثر من
نصف مليار رقم تم تسريبها تقريبا كل
السعوديه كل ارقام المواطنين والمقيمين في
السعوديه ايضا تم تسريبها على تطبيق
الواتساب
اختراق وتهكير ولا العمليه مقصوده التسريب
بغرض البيع يعني
خالد اليوم ما تم تسريبه هي بيانات جدا
جدا هامه كيف تم تسريبها هي في عام 2019
اغراء في شبكه فيسبوك حاليا استقل لها
المغترقون بطريقه همم يعني احترافيه قاموا
من خلالها يعني سحب عدد هائل من هذه
البيانات اللي تجاوزت النصف مليار
مستخدم همم
ما الذي حدث همم في الكواليس لا نعلم ولكن
في ظني انه شركه فيسبوك اذا ارادت بيع مثل
هذه البيانات ستقوم ببيعها بطرق اخرى لن
تتيحها للعموم على شبكه الانترنت لانه هذه
البيانات اصبحت للاسف متاحه في في وقت
سابق على احد المنتديات المتخصصه في الهكر
يستطيع الشخص الوصول همم لها الشخص
المختصر الرسول لها هذا كمل هائل من
البيانات بطبيعه الحال همم
لانه ملياردير الامريكي اللي هو همم مالك
مات همم مارك ذكر بيرج قال بانه يتطلع الى
زياده ارادته عبر خطوه قد لا تنال رضا بعض
المستخدمين لتطبيق همم الواتساب والماسنجر
عبر يعني فرض رسومه واشتراك شهري على
التطبيق يمكن
حمايه مثلا للواتساب
يجب عليك ان تدفع رسوم هل ذلك يعني
فيسبوك همم البيانات
احيانا تقول وتتعامل مع شركات اطراف ثالث
وتقوم فعليا ببيع بيانات المستخدمين
والكسب من وراءها فيسبوك لا تملك همم يعني
اجهزه لا تملك اي اشياء محسوسه القيمه
السوقيه الهايله للفيسبوك هي قيمه
البيانات وكل ما زادت هذه البيانات كل ما
استطاعت فعليا تزيد من قيمتها السوقيه
تسريبها للسوق سيجعل من هذه القيمه
السوقيه تنزل وفيسبوك ليست بصراحه في موضع
تستطيع تحمل المزيد من خسائر الفتره
الماضيه نزل سهامها الى قرابه النصف همم
خسر او تجاوز خرج من قائمه همم اكبر همم
على مستوى العالم همم
اصبح في المرتبه السابعه عشر فلذلك في
تخيلي فيسبوك تعاني معاناه كبيره جدا في
مساله الحفاظ على همم سريه البيانات لدى
المستخدمه يعني فبالتالي
ايش خطوره هذا الامر عليه
فعلا الخطر العالي من تسريب مثل هذه
البيانات في راي تسريب بيانات الارقام
السريه وتسريب بيانات بطاقات همم البنكيه
اهون بكثير من تسريب البيانات الشخصيه
لانه اذا تم تسريب الارقام السريه او
بيانات البطاقات البنكيه بالامكان تغييرها
في ثواني قليله لكن تسريب البيانات
الشخصيه لا يمكن تغييرها البيانات التي تم
تسريبها هي بيانات جدا هامه بيانات ارقام
الجوال البيانات همم اللوكيشن البيانات
الشخصيه للمستخدمين تم تسريب حسابات
الفيسبوك المرتبطه بهذه البيانات همم
بارقام الجوال تم تسريب في طبيعه الحال
كذلك الدول التي يعيش فيها هؤلاء اشخاص
هذه البيانات في حال تم تسريبها وقد تم
ذلك سيتم فعليا استخدامها ربما الاستخدام
السيء 28 مليون رقم وبيانات تم تسريبها
مثلا المواطنين في السعوديه سيتم خلالها
التالي على سبيل المثال استهدا وهمم ربما
حملات مغرضه
استهدافهم ربما بي يعني الهندسه العكسيه
وانتحال الشخصيات وانتحال الشركات وسرقه
الاموال همم تسريب البيانات الشخصيه لاي
همم مجموعه في المجتمع سيكون عرضه لي يعني
الهجمات التي يعني همم تستهدف هذه الفئه
اما كانت سرقه اموال واما كانت ربما تغيير
افكار واما كانت ربما حتى همم جعلهم همم
تجيش العواطف لديهم بطريقه سلبيه بطريقه
اخرى لانه اتاحت هذه البيانات الشخصيه
سيتيح حصول المباشر
يعني افترض انه رقمي الان هو مسرب
فبالتالي شو المفروض انه كيف اتعامل مع
الموقف طبعا اليوم هذا التسريب بطبيعه
الحال فيسبوك ليس الاول من عام 2018
والبيانات تتسرب عام بعد عام في عام 2018
تم تسريب 92,000,000 عام
مثل هذه البيانات بطبيعه حاسه تجعل
بياناتنا معروضه في السوق همم السودان كان
صاحب التعبير يجب علينا عدم التفاعل معه
الرسائل او همم
يعني التواصل الغريب عدم التفاعل مع في
الواتساب في الواتساب
خلال الفتره الجايه من اشخاص وهميين همم
ممكن همم بغرض الاحتيال ربما في اكثر من
مجال فبالتالي التعامل معها باهمالها هل
يوفر هذا الامر الحمايه ولا يجب عليك كمان
انه انت كمان تتحرك بشكل اكثر همم فقط عن
طريق الواتساب لانه وجود رقم جوالك قناتك
الاساسيه لدى المخترق يستغل اا سواء
الواتساب او حتى الرسائل قصيره او اي
وسيله ربما اخرى لاستهدفك همم لاي غرض من
الاغراض يجب عليك فعليا التنبؤ بل حتى
يعني بطبيعه الحال وصلتك الرساله من اقرب
الاقربين اليك لا تتفاعل معها الا بعد
التاكد من معاييرها فعلى سبيل المثال اي
رابط يطلب منك معلومات لا تتفاعل معه ابدا
همم ما يتعلق حتى بروابط تحميل التطبيقات
وغيره يجب عليه
كمان يعني انت تقول ان المساله ما هتجيء
لك ممكن رقم شخص وتبت ان تكون محفوظ رقمي
اه لانه هو في النهايه الهندسه العكسيه ما
الذي يتم عن طريقها قد يتم اختراق قد يتم
اختراق يعني همم
ارسل للمخترق الرقم السري ب- بهندسه عكسيه
كانه يطلب مني دفع مبلغ معين او غيره
اتفعل معه يخترق حسابي اتواصل انا معك
اخوي خالد يقول انا عبد العزيز همم اخوي
خالد لو سمحت تحتاج منك المعلومات
الاضافيه او تحويل مبلغ مالي او تحميل
رابط معين او التفاعل مع صفحه معينه فلن
ياتيك من شخص غريب سياتيك من شخص تعرف نعم
فلذلك لا تتفاعل ويجب عليك فعليا الحذر
التام من اي معلومات او روابط او حتى ربما
اا يعني تفاعل ما يعرف
لن نستطيع لانه سنكون في معزه العالم
تفاعل مع الواتساب في الوقت الحالي ولكن
بحذر عالي خاصه مع تسريب البيانات العالي
الذي همم قد يكون في المستقبل اخوي خالد
الحل وانا شخص يكون عنده رقمين رقم يستخدم
بطريقه
هذه الايام مثل ما يكون عندنا اليوم عده
ارقام بطاقات بنكيه قد يكون في المستقبل
الحاليه بعد هذا التسريب بهذا التسريب
وصول ارقام الجوالات الى هذه
المخترقين سيجعل من الصعب فعلا الامر شكر
الله شكرا جزيلا لك خبيره التقنيه عبد
العزيز في الحمام دي